for us here at et the party usually
starts in palm springs
there will also be big changes to that
festival because of the pandemic but the
show will go on
we teamed up with the palm springs
international film awards to kick off
award season viola davis and riz ahmed
will receive the desert palm
achievement award they join past winners
like renee zellweger matthew mcconaughey
and julianne moore
who all went on to win oscar gold every
once in a while something comes along
and it's exactly
what you dreamed it would be gary oldman
will receive the chairman's award and
sir anthony hopkins will be honored with
this year's career achievement award
the greatest accolade is to be still
working and keep an eye out for these
power women
director chloe zao ya jung yoon andra
day
and kerry mulligan
fans love daniel kahlua in judas and the
black messiah and
yaya abdul mateen ii along with the
entire cast of the trial of the chicago
seven
they pick up the vanguard award it's
very rare that you can get i think
talent life was like what was assembled
from top to bottom for this group
[Music]
leslie odom jr's real life pipes paid
tribute to sam cook and landed him the
spotlight awards
it was spicy when people talk about
saying people that knew him
it was not that you know smooth crooner
guy that we saw on the tonight's show
oh yellow yellow yellow of course stars
like brad love this
laid-back award show just as much as we
do this year will be all virtual tune in
to et february 25th
as we celebrate all the big winners oh
my goodness
you